it looks now that there have been four
allegations against this presenter
yeah I mean just a flood of allegations
now coming forward which does make you
really question how feasible it is for
this presenter in question to remain
anonymous really on many levels the BBC
is now looking bad on this for one
you've just played a an interview out
that the director General gave to the
world at one the fact that the BBC all
of us broadcasters who have been outside
of here have asked have put in requested
again again to speak to the director
General and the fact that he has only
given an interview to his own people
that is not a good look for the BBC but
also they now look bad for how slowly
they acted in terms of addressing that
initial complaint to take seven weeks
before they actually spoke to the
presenter in question we now know from
that timeline that you uh we were given
yesterday that you just explained the
initial investigations team they only
sent one email and made one phone call
that didn't connect to the initial
complainant in order to try to verify
this claim so they did very little in
terms of following this up until the the
claims actually came out in the sun but
as well as that they now look bad of
course because you have this hypocrisy
element coming into it the BBC was the
institution that delivered all of the
rules to the BBC that set out what we
should be doing during lockdown and to
now know that this presenter in question
was breaking these covid rules well
again now the BBC looks hypocritical on
this and just how feasible it is to
argue that it isn't in the public
interest to name this person well I
think now really the pressure is on the
BBC to perhaps uh answer our questions
and be a bit more open about this